[Musique]
pour
face au fait que dans mon esprit j'avais été
remplacé, viens Dieu a besoin de savoir
maintenant alors veux-
moi
[Musique]
mon c'est seulement dur c'est seulement
4° c'est seulement 4° c'est seulement 4°
de c'est seulement  pour theg c'est seulement pour le
c'est seulement 4° c'est seulement
[Musique]
4° je veux voir ce monde je veux le
voir
Bo je veux voir ce monde je veux le
voir plus c'est
seulement 4° c'est seulement
4° c'est  seulement 4° c'est seulement
[Musique]
4°
[Musique] [
Musique]
il [
Musique] [
Musique]
maintenant [
la [
Musique] [
Musique]
ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
une
oh [
Musique]
c'est juste un peu sombre construit sur
une seule
note d'autres notes B à suivre mais la
racine est toujours cette
note maintenant cette nouvelle est la conséquence
du mur que nous venons de traverser
mais comme je suis forcément la
conséquence inévitable de
toi, il y a tellement de gens qui peuvent parler
et parler et parler et ne rien dire
ou presque rien. J'ai l'habitude d'être sur la
balance et je sais qu'à la fin je n'ai
rien trouvé.  ou presque
rien donc je reviens sur cette première
note comme je dois revenir vers toi je
verserai dans cette seule note tout l'amour que je
ressens pour toi quiconque regarde toute l'
émission r
[Musique]
il se retrouvera sans émission mieux
joue ça, tu ne sais pas
[Musique]